the latest on that massive winter storm
moving into the northeast after causing
havoc in many other parts of the country
the midwest is digging out from more
than a foot of snow today snowfall could
reach 18 inches in parts of ohio new
york and northern new england in other
areas they're covered in ice because of
the freezing rain hundreds of thousands
of homes and businesses have lost power
in alabama a tornado killed one person
yesterday and injured eight others
manuela jorquez is at the scene in
sawyerville alabama manuel good morning
good morning nate a very difficult
morning for many here in alabama the
reason behind me is pretty clear homes
that have been heavily damaged or like
this one destroyed by the tornado ripped
in half the contents of the furniture
now visible from the outside now winter
tornadoes are indeed less common but
scientists say even in the winter the
atmospheric conditions that produce
tornadoes have intensified they believe
due to a warming planet
the tornado that touched down here in
hale county thursday caused a wide path
of destruction fueled by high winds from
the winter storm the twister cut through
multiple homes shredded trees that
littered roadways and even caused enough
flooding to swallow vehicles
in lebanon missouri a clear sign of the
treacherous road conditions as a
semi-trailer flipped off the side of
interstate 44
one driver struggled to get his car back
on the road as multiple vehicles were
stranded by the heavy snowfall
elsewhere across the deep south a deep
freeze plunging temperatures leaving
more than a hundred thousand without
power in tennessee as the storm moved
through the state in memphis trees
buckled under the weight of ice and
crashed into homes as drivers slid off
highways
temperatures dropped so low in belmont
county ohio the mixture of freezing rain
sleet and ice forced officials to
declare a level two emergency warning
drivers to stay off the highways i'm
going to my mothers to be rescued to get
warm meanwhile in texas the sub freezing
temperatures are leaving thousands
without electricity as utility workers
cut back trees heavy with ice and snow
threatening to damage power lines many
in texas are worried about a repeat of
last year's deadly power crisis deja vu
right last year same
thing the national weather service
called the tornado that ripped through
this part of alabama large and extremely
dangerous the one confirmed fatality is
a woman whose mobile home was flung
across her street
gail wow those pictures tell quite a
story thank you manny